Ron DeSantis is looking to cut the
diversity
equity and inclusion staff at
universities DeSantis
has said that he plans to quote
eliminate all Dei and CRT bureaucracies
in the State of Florida such that the
programs Wither on the vine that's
wonderful wonderful news in recent years
the Dei programs at these universities
have just multiplied and now it seems
like for every one student for every one
Professor there were three Deans and
Deputy Deans and Deputy assistant Deputy
deans of diversity inclusion and
stirring up a bunch of racial and sexual
resentment to the tune of four hundred
thousand dollars a year per employee and
it's just it's just a disaster
so desanta says he's going to fire all
of them
great stuff